[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم قال وزير الخارجيه السعودي
عادل الجبير ان المملكه وتركيا اتفقتا على
انشاء مجلس تعاون استراتيجي لتعزيز
التعاون العسكري والاقتصادي والاستثماري
بين البلدين نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما الانعكاسات المرتقبه للتوافق
السعويه التركي على اهم خلافات
المنطقه وكيف سيؤثر هذا التوافق على مواقف
المعارضه السوريه في معادلات الازمه
ومساعي
حلها توافق سعودي تركي على انشاء مجلس
تعاون استراتيجي تمخضت عنه زياره الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان الى المملكه والتوافق
ينظر اليه على انه قد يغير الكثير من
ملامح الاوضاع والملفات في المنطقه في وقت
بات فيه الجميع ينظر بكثير من الاهتمام
والترقب الى خارطه التحالفات والتوازنات
تقرير فاطمه
التريكي السعوديه وتركيا معا بعدما بد
لهما ان ما يجمعهما اكثر مما يفرق وان
الاحتياج المتبادل صار ملحا في وجه
محاولات العزل والاضعف لحساب احلاف مضاده
بحفاوه بالغه استقبل الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان في الرياض وبعد محادثات مع
العاهل السعودي وكبار المسؤولين اعلن عن
توافق لاقامه مجلس للتعاون الاستراتيجي
بين البلدين سياسي وعسكري واقتصادي وثقافي
في مؤتمر صحفي قال وزير خارجيه البلدين ان
البحث تركز في في قضايا اليمن والعراق
والحرب على الارهاب وطبعا سوريا القضيه
الاهم وتوافق البلدان على ان لا مستقبل
لبشار الاسد في سوريا ما يعني اصراره ما
على رحيله عن السلطه وهو مطلب تم تمييعه
امريكيا ودوليا يمثل تحالف انقره الرياض
تتويجا لتقارب بلغ ذروته الربيع الماضي
حين كثر الحديث يومها عن احتمال تشكيل حلف
ذي طابع عسكري للتدخل في سوريا وترافق مع
دعم لفصائل في المعارضه المسلحه مكنها من
تحقيق دفاعه صاعقه ضد قوات النظام في ادلب
وسهل الغاب حين ذاك وصل نظام الاسد الى
اضعف حالاته قبل ان يحدث التدخل الروسي
الصريح تحت عنوان انقاذه والمستمر الى
الان بالتعامل كقوه وحيده تفرض الشروط
وتتصرف عسكريا باعتبار كل من يقاتله
ارهابيا قبل اسبوع قتلت روسيا زهران علوش
قائد جيش الاسلام الذي شارك في اجتماعات
الرياض والاسد نظاما وشخصا ليس مجرد عقده
في ازمه بل هو قلب ما يصفه خبراء بصعود
الشيعيه السياسيه الايرانيه التي تمددت في
المنطقه حتى تفاخرت بسيطرتها على عواصم
الشرق الاهم وقد تلاقت مصلحه واهداف مع
قياده روسيه تطمح الى دور تاريخي في شرق
متروك هنا بدات المنطقه لغالب سكانها امام
مازق استراتيجي واسئله تلامس الوجود
والهويه الامر الذي يراه كثيرون احد اهم
اسباب التط لقد بدا ما يوصف بلقاء القطبين
السنيين بالمعنى الجيوسياسي اكثر من ضروره
ذاتيه قد يفتح التحالف الجديد عيونا ترقب
في موسكو وتتوجس في طهران وتقلق في
القاهره لكنها السياسه حيث عدو الصديق ليس
عدوا بالضروره لا سما ان كانت صداقته
مجديه
نرحب بضيفي في هذه الحلقه من جده الدكتور
عبد العزيز بن صقر رئيس مركز الخليج
للابحاث ومن بيروت الدكتور فواز جرجس
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه ومدير مركز الشرق
الاوسط في جامعه لندن دكتور عبد العزيز بن
صقر اي اثر تتوقع لهذا التوافق السعودي
التركي اولا مساء الخير لك ولضيوفك
ومشاهدين الجزيره في كل مكان حقيقه هذه
ليست الزياره الا للرئيس اردوغان في ال 11
شهر الماضي يمكن هذه الزياره الرابعه له
المملكه العربيه السعوديه فشهد تطور ملحوظ
العلاقه بين المملكه وما بين تركيا
والتنسيق في الكثير من القضايا هذا
الاتفاق الذي اعلن عنه المجلس التنسيقي في
الاستراتيجي بدون شك هو جاي لعده اسباب
السبب الاول منه ان هنالك فراغ انوجد في
المنطقه بسبب غياب وتراجع وذبذبه وعدم
وضوح السياسه الامريكيه في المنطقه والتي
سمحت بدورها للوجود الروسي بهذا الشكل
وتدخله في سوريا واحتلالها الاراضي
السوريه
واستخدامها الاراضي السوريه للقيام باعمال
قتل الابرياء في في سوريا فهنالك فراغ هذا
الفراغ اوجد ضروره ملحه جدا لسرعه التنسيق
في ما بين هذا التكتل الذي نشا بسبب غياب
و عدم وضوح السياسه الامريكيه في المنطقه
وجدت المملكه وتركيا واللي لها وبعض دول
الخليج مثل قطر ان لها مصلحه بايجاد تنسيق
كبير في ما بينها فيما يتعلق بدعم
المعارضه المعتدله على الارض ومساعدتها
حتى تقوم بعملياتها للتخلص من وضع نظام
بشار الاسد والتي ايدت كل الدول تركيا
والسعوديه والاخرين على خروجه وضروره
خروجه وايضا هذا التنسيق نحن امام مفترق
طرق الان فيما يتعلق بالملف السوري الملف
السوري سوف يتجه اما الى مفاوضات مجديه
وتعطي نتيجه وتصل بها الى حلول او انها لا
نصل الى مفاوضات وفي الحاله هذه هذا
التحالف سوف يمثل دعم واستراتيجيه مهمه في
علاقته مع قوى المعارضه على الارض
المعتدله والتي سوف تستمر في قتالها فهو
في كلا الحالتين مهم مهم ان يخرج من
العباءه الامريكيه والمواقف الامريكيه
المذبذبه وعدم الواضحه وهذه التي سمحت
للوجود الروسي بهذا الشكل وبالتاكيد
المصلحه الامريكيه في الوجود الروسي
منبعها قضيتين الاولى هي تريد الاتفاق
النووي ان يستمر وروسيا لها دور مهم في
هذا الجانب وايضا اهميته تاتي في ان
الولايات المتحده لا تريد ان تقاتل في في
سوريا فتفضل ان يقوم بهذا الدور الجانب
الروسي
ولكن انا اشب الوضع الحالي معلش بس انا في
نقطه بسيطه نقطه بسيطه
استاذ الوضع الحالي بالنسبه لي يذكرني
بدور باكستان في افغانستان والتعاون الذي
حدث بينها وبين المملكه في ذلك الوقت
تركيا لها 650 كيلو حدود مع سوريا هذا
الدور الذي يمكن ان تقوم به تركيا بدعم
وتنسيق وتكتل في مواجهه روسيا وايران هذه
قضيه
مهمه يعني بعد اذ اذا تركنا اذا تركنا
الموضوع اذا تركنا الموضوع السوري لان
سنعود الى تفصيله
بشكل اعمق في المحور الثاني اذا تركنا هذا
الموضوع الدكتور فواز
جرجس احد
المحللين الاتراك يقول بان ما سهل هذا
التقارب التركي السعودي هو خ امل انقره
والرياض من السياسات الامريكيه في المنطقه
هل تعتقد بان هذا نقطه مفصليه في هذا
الموضوع هي بالفعل نقطه مهمه للغايه
الفراغ القيادي الدولي في المنطقه ولكن لا
اعتقد ان القضيه الامريكيه بهذه الاهميه
لان كلا المملكه العربيه السعوديه وتركيا
يعني جزء لا يتجزا من التحالف التي تقوده
الولايات المتحده نحن لا نتكلم عن اي خلاف
نظري او عملي على الارض نحن نتكلم الحقيقه
الان عن ان هذا قضيه انشاء هذا التحالف
يشيع الى الى قضيه محوريه الا وهي
الاصطفاف الاقليمي الحاد وضوح في طبيعه
المحاور في المنطقه نتحدث عن محورين
المحور السعودي التركي القطري من جهه
والمحور الايراني السوري العراقي من جهه
اخرى هناك ملفين ا يعني واعتقد ان هذا
التحالف هو تحالف الحقيقه مصالح بامتياز
ماذا تريد تركيا من هذا التحالف تركيا
لتركيا الملف السوري هو الملف الاستراتيجي
الان تركيا دخلت في مواجهه مفتوحه في
سوريا طبعا منذ اربع سنوات واكثر وخاصه
بعد التدخل الروسي ا التدخل الروسي غير
خلط من الاوراق في سوريا الوضع خطير جدا
من نظر القياده التركيه وخاصه بعد
المواجهه الاخيره واسقاط
الطائره الروسيه تركيا تريد دعما من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وخاصه ان الملف
السوري وقضيه الاكراد مهمه جدا واسقاط
النظام السوري ماذا تريد المملكه العربيه
السعوديه المملكه العربيه السعوديه اذا
تمعنا جيدا بما تحدث عنه الرئيس التركي
والقياده السعوديه انا اعتقد ان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تريد من تركيا دورا مهما
في دعم المملكه في اليمن الوضع في اليمن
خطير للغايه لا اعتقد ان قضيه الحسم
العسكري في اليمن قد نجحت الى ذ الى يعني
حد بعيد هناك توازن رعب في اليمن المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تنظر الى ايران على انها
خطر وجودي ومن خلال هذا التكتل انا لا
اعتقد انه تحالف هو تكتل علينا ان ن ننتظر
لنرى طبيعه هذا التكتل المملكه تريد من
تركيا ان تعطيها زخما في هذا الصراع
الوجود مع عيران مع انني اعتقد ان تركيا
تمسك العصر العصا من منتصفه مع ايران طبعا
هي تريد مساعده المملكه في اليمن ولكن
تركيا لن تقطع شعرت معاويه مع ايران
العلاقات التركيا الايرانيه تاريخيه
اقتصاديه استراتيجيه لدرجه كبيره نتكلم عن
حوالي 30 مليار سنوي في السنوات القادمه
ولكن هناك مصالح لكلا المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وتركيا لان تحاول حقيقه ملء هذا
الفراغ الموجود في الملفين الملف السوري
والملف اليمني الايراني خصوصا نعم في في
الموضوع الايراني تحديدا دكتور بن
صقر السيد انور عشقي وهو رئيس مركز الشرق
الاوسط للدراسات الاستراتيجيه اشر الى
نقطه مهمه في هذا الموضوع قال بان طموح
انقره والرياض هو كما قال كبح جماح ايران
واعادتها الى الحضيره الاسلاميه بطريقه
سلميه كلا البلدين مثل ما اشار الدكتور
فواز جرجس لديهم هذا
التوجس من ايران ما الذي يمكن ان يتغير
بعد ان اصبح اصبحت العلاقه في شكل تكتل
كما قال الدكتور او تحالف او نسميه ما
شانه هنالك مصالح مشتركه وهنالك تنسيق في
الموا قف السعوديه وتركيا ترى ان النفوذ
الايراني في العراق وفي سوريا غير مقبول
وان استخدام هذا البعد على سبيل المثال
تركيا حينما تدخلت في شمال العراقيه تدخلت
بموجب موافقه امريكيه وطلب من قوات البش
مر وحكومه كردستان وبالمقابل الحكومه
العراقيه اعتراضها لم تعترض حينما تدخلت
ايران الى 50 كيلو في خانقين وتواجدت
لابعد من ذلك وتواجدت في كل شبر من اراضي
العراق ويصول ويجول قادتها العسكريون في
في العراق بهذا الشكل تركيا ترى ان هنالك
خطوره بالنسبه لها فيما يتعلق بوضع الموصل
وتطورات الموقف هنالك فهي بحاجه الى دعم
المملكه فيما يتعلق بخطواتها في العراق
وموقفها فيما يتعلق بالحدود الامنه مع
العراق ايضا سوريا مهمه بالنسبه لها و
لديها التركمان ولديها فئات ولديها حدود
طويله وايضا هي هي تقف نفس الموقف الذي
تقفه المملكه من ضروره مغادره بشار الاسد
ولا وجوده له في مستقبل سوريا ايران
بالمقابل تستخدم هذا النفوذ وتعمق نفوذها
وهي سياسه تدخليه حاولت ايران ان تفرض هذا
النمط من السياسه التداخليه في العراق وفي
سوريا حتى تبسط نفوذ بالنسبه لها فالتقاه
المصالح هنا والنقطه اللي اشار اليها
الدكتور جرجس وانا ذكرتها قبل ان هنالك
فراغ وهذا الفراغ سببه السياسه الامريكيه
المتردده الغير واضحه في بعض الاحيان
الفيتو الامريكي الذي يستخدم على التسليح
لقوى المعارضه عدم امكانيات هذ يجعل ان
هنالك ضروره ملحه لتعاون اكبر بين المملكه
وتركيا في فيما يتعلق بالتعامل مع ملفات
المنطقه لن يوازي النفوذ الايراني السافر
والتدخل بهذا الشكل الا وجود تركي سواء في
سوريا او في العراق حتى يوازي ويكون هنالك
معادله في هذا الجانب انت لمن سوف تتجه في
هذه المنطقه اذا كان الحليف الرئيسي
الولايات المتحده سياساته مذبذبه امس يعني
على سبيل المثال على فكره وهذا الموقف
الامريكي المخذلين ما ترسل ايران صاروخا
يعني تعطي التنبيه قبل 23 دقيقه من ارساله
وقريب من البارجه الامريكيه كيلو ونص
تقريبا من هذا وترد الولايات المتحده
بانها تستنكر لو هذا كان في زمن غير
الرئيس اوباما لوجدنا رده فعل امريكيه
مختلفه بهذا الشكل ولن تسمح بهذا السفور
الايراني وهذا التمدد وهذه العنجهيه وهذا
الاستعلاء والاستكبار وهذا التجاوز في كل
المعايير التي لها علاقه بامن الخليج
وسياس واستقراره وهذا هذا هذا
هذا الاستخدام المفرط يعني بالنسبه لها
في لا هناك ايضا مساله اخرى هناك ايضا
مساله اخرى تتعلق ب موضوع الارهاب دكتور
جرجس رغم ان كثيرين لم يشيروا الى هذا هذا
التحالف الاخير الذي اعلنته
الرياض هل تعتقد بان هذا التقارب
التركي السعودي يمكن ان يؤثر في طبيعه هذا
التحالف او في
عمله يعني حتى الان الولايات المتحده هي
التي تقود التحالف ضد الارهاب حتى الان لا
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ولا تركيا
الحائيه تلعب دورا محوريا في هذا الملف
انا اتكلم تحليليا ولا سياسيا علينا ان لا
نبالغ في اهميه يعني الدور الذي سوف تلعبه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه عسكريا وتركيا
عسكريا يعني القضيه الاستراتيجيه لتركيا
هي ليست قضيه الارهاب هي قضيه منع الاكراد
من انشاء يعني كيان مستقل ا على الحدود
التركيه السوريه واسقاط النظام السوري
طبعا تركيا هي جزء لا يتجزا من التحالف
الامريكي في سوريا ولكن لا تعطي قضيه
الارهاب يعني الاهميه التي تعطيها الدول
الغربيه والولايات المتحده المملكه
العربيه السعوديه المحور الملف الاهم
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه هو الملف اليمني
المملكه العربيه السعوديه دخلت في مواجهه
مفتوحه مع ايران ليس فقط في سوريا ولكن
ايضا في العراق وفي اليمن يعني هناك نوع
ال المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تحاول الاعتماد على تركيا لقضيه
الردع ايران لانه بالفعل اذا نظرنا الى
الخارطه الاقليميه ايران حققت انجازات
يعني تكتيكيه مهمه في الخارطه يعني
السياسيه في المنطقه العربيه ولكنني اعتقد
وبكل تواضع ان تركيا لن تعطي المملكه ال
يعني القوه الزخم الاستراتيجي ضد ايران
تركيا لن تدخل في صراع مع ايران تركيا
دوله محوريه تنظر الى ايران على انها دوله
محوريه ايضا العلاقات تاريخيه ولكن تركيا
سوف تحاول مساعده المملكه في الملف اليمني
لان الملف اليمني وصل الى طريق مسدود
تركيا يمكن ان ان تعطي زخما للموقف
السعودي
في يعني اليمن ومع ذلك انا اعتقد يعني انه
تحالف مصالح لان ايضا تركيا تريد هي هي
استثمار في قضيه الطاقه وخاصه بعد
المواجهه العسكريه مع روسيا محاوله ايجاد
مصادر للطاقه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وفي قطر نعم ايه اشرنا اشرنا في في هذا
الجزء الى الملف السوري لانه لا يمكن ان
نهمله ولكن نريد ان نتطرق بعد الفاصل الى
تاثير هذا التقارب او هذا التحالف او هذا
التكتل السعودي التركي على مواقف المعارضه
السوريه في المرحله المقبله لن عوده نرجو
ان تبقوا معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها هذا التوافق
السعودي التركي الاخير والذي توج بانشاء
مجلس يعبر عن علاقات جديده خاصه الكتور
عبد العزيز بن
صقر ليس سرا بان تركيا والسعوديه وقطر تقف
بقوه الى جانب المعارضه السوريه سياسيا
وعسكريا الان بعد هذا التقارب والذي لم
يكن متوفرا في السابق بين تركيا والسعوديه
ما الذي يمكن ان يتغير في مواقف المعارضه
بتقديرك يعني انا اعتقادي هي جزئيتين مثل
يمكن ما ذكرت لك في في السابق في كلا
الحالتين هذا التنسيق وهذا التعاون مهم
جدا اذا نجح الحل السياسي واخذت خطوات
سياسيه مهمه والمجتمع الدولي مارس ضغطه
الحقيق حقيقي على الحكومه السوريه وعلى
روسيا للوصول الى الى اتفاق مستند الى
جنيف واحد فهذا يعني ما يتمناه الكل حتى
يوفر على الشعب السوري ويلات وتبعات
العمليات العسكريه واثارها على جميع
الاطراف في حال عدم نجاح هذا الحل السياسي
فهو معناته استمرار لدعم المقاومه
السوريه بشكل اقوى وافضل من السابق هذا
يعني ان تركيا قادره ان تقدم السلاح دول
الخليج السعوديه وقطر قادره ان تدعم هذا
الجانب مع مع تركيا تركيا لها علاقه
سياسيه وعسكريه وامنيه مع معظم الفصائل
السياسيه والعسكريه في سوريا المقاومه
لوجود بشار الاسد والتي تريد ان تتخلص من
هذا النظام فسوف تدفع بقوه نحو دعم
المعارضه وبشكل اكبر وتتجاوز فيه الفيتو
السابق الذي كان يفرض في اوقات معينه على
تسليح المعارضه ببعض انواع الاسلحه نحن
وجدنا حينما مكنت المعارضه من ا الصواريخ
المقاومه للدروع في اقل من اسبوع استطاعت
ان تدمر اكثر من 16 160 مدرعه
ا وهذا كان انجاز يعني جيد بالنسبه لها ما
تحتاجه المقاومه المعتدله على الارض
السوريه في الوقت الحاضر هو تمكينها
وازاله الفيتو في هذا الجانب وتمكينها
بشكل اقوى وتركيا قادره ان تقدم هذا
التمكين مثل ما ذكرت لك سابقا تركيا
تستطيع ان تلعب دور مهم مثل الدور الذي
لعبته الباكستان في المقاومه الافغانيه في
فيذلك الوقت وممكن بالدعم والتنسيق هنا
يكون هنالك تنسيق سياسي وتنسيق عسكري
وتنسيق امني هذا المجلس هو يحتمل كل هذه
انواع التنسيق طبعا انا اتمنى انه لا يعدي
علينا الوقت وننسى بعد ذلك ولكن اتمنى ان
يكون هنالك تفعيل مباشر لكل هذه القضايا
التي تم الاتفاق عليها في هذا المجلس
التنسيقي لمصلحه جميع الاطراف نحن نريد
تركيا قويه داعمه معنا في القضايا التي
تهمنا لا نريد نفوذ ايراني ان يتوسع في في
المنطقه اكثر في هذا الجانب ولا نريد
احتلال روسي لبلد مثل سوريا لان هذه يعني
سابقه خطيره وسوف تؤدي الى توسع يعني
روسيا لن تقف عند حدود سوريا ولكنها سوف
تتوسع بعد ذلك ومع الاسف الاخوه في العراق
اذا يعتقدون ان النفوذ الروسي لن يطالهم
ولن ياتيهم فهم مخطئون في هذا الجانب ولكن
ولكن ولكن ولكن بالنسبه لسوريا معذره
دكتور بالنسبه لسوريا كيف يمكن لتركيا وا
السعوديه ان تكون اكثر نفوذا دكتور جرجس
ان تكون اكثر نفوذا في دعم المعارضه
السوريه المسلحه دون ان تسقط بالضروره في
ايجاد الفراغ الذي يمكن ان يستفيد منه
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه الذي هو محل
محاربه الجميع
تقريبا يعني اولا نقطه نظريه النقطه
النظريه الاولى ان هذا التحالف هذا التكتل
هذا الاصطفاف الاقليمي المحورين الحقيقه
يشير و للاسف واتمنى ان اكون مخطئا الى ان
فرص الحل السياسي في سوريا ضئيله للغايه
الكلمه الاولى والاخيره في هذه اللحظه هي
للميدان يعني هناك توازي في المسارين
المسار السياسي الذي سوف يبدا في اواخر
الشهر القادم وخاصه من خلال جلوس الاطراف
المتصارعه في سوريا والمسار العسكري يعني
الان بالفعل اهميه هذا التكتل التكتل لم
يبدا في هذه اللحظه كما تعلم التكتل عمره
حوالي سبعه اشهر واستطاع تحقيق انجازات
ميدانيه في مهمه وخاصه في ادلب و وحمص
وبعض الملفات الاخرى طبعا التدخل الروسي
خلط الاوراق الجيش السوري انتقل من الوضع
الدفاعي الخطير الى الوضع الهجومي لم يتم
تغيير ميزان القوى عسكريا ولكن الان الجيش
السوري لديه القدره الزخم والدفع وال
الهجوم ومن هنا انا اعتقد هذا التكتل الان
وهذا العلن الوضوح في الرؤيه هناك بعض
التقارير الجديه الغربيه تتحدث على ان
تركيا والمملكه وقطر يتحدثون عن ارسال
صواريخ ضد الطائرات وليس ضد الدروع مع
انني اعتقد ان الفيتو الامريكي ما يزال
موجودا حتى الان ولا علينا ان لا ننسى ان
هناك قوات امريكيه خاصه ما بين 50 و1 ضابط
امريكي على الحدود التركيه السوريه يديرون
المعركه ضد داعش مع قوات الاكراد والتحالف
العربي ومن هنا الحقيقه السؤال المهم يعني
احد الاسباب الرئيسيه التي ادت الى اعلان
هذا التحالف الوضع الميداني الخطير في
سوريا ليس فقط يعني في درعا ليس فقط في
حلب ولكن طبعا في جبال اللاذقيه حيث ان
المصالح التركيه الحيويه موجوده وتتخوف
تركيا من ان روسيا سوف تلعب بالورقه
الكرديه لان بالفعل روسيا بدات ترد
وبطريقه خطيره على تركيا ومن هنا الحقيقه
محاول و لايجاد خيارات ل منع حدوث اختراق
خطير من قبل الجيش السوري ضد قوات
المعارضه التي بدات بالفعل تحدث في بعض
الجبهات في سوريا نعم اشرت الى الصواريخ
المضاده للطائرات دكتور بن صقر في نهايه
البرنامج البعض وصل في في تحليله وربما في
في امانيه ان نصل الى حد تدخل تركي سعودي
عسكري في في سوريا يمكن ان ان تصل الامور
الى هذا الحد
بتقديرك يعني قوه التحالف الاسلامي
لمكافحه الارهاب رب ربما تكون مظله جديده
تسمح بهذا التدخل سواء لتركيا في الموصل
او في او في سوريا هذا يعني قضيه مطروحه
ممكن ان تطرح وان ان يبحث بشكل كامل
اعتقادي انه جديه هذا التحالف او هذا
التكتل سوف تدفع بهم الى اخذ مواقف قويه
ولن تقف مكتوفه الايدي امام التكتل يران
العراقي السوري في هذا الجانب يعني
بالتاكيد الفيتو الامريكي الذي استخدم
وكان له سلبياته الكبيره وادى الى ما ادى
اليه ربما هذه الدول سوف تضطر انها بدعم
من تركيا تركيا تمتلك الصواريخ المضاده
للطائرات وكثير من الدول وليس فقط امريكا
يعني ربما سوف تضطر الى هذا العمل وهنالك
يعني بعض مؤشرات تشير الى هذا الجانب ربما
تدريب بعض العناصر تاهيل تجهيزهم لهذه
المرحله شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور دكتور عبد
العزيز بن صقر رئيس مركز الخليج للابحاث
من جده شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من بيروت الدكتور
فواد جرجس استاذ العلاقات الدوليه ومدير
مركز الشرق الاوسط في جامعه لندن في نهايه
هذه الحلقه نتمنى لكم عاما جديدا سعيدا
وكل عام وانتم بخير في امان
[موسيقى]
الله
ه